Pendant deux ans, les biologistes Alain Butet
et Grégoire Perez, au laboratoire Ecobio
à Rennes, ont étudié les tiques. Ils en
ont récolté plus de 4 000, dans la forêt
et dans les champs, et découvert que 4 % des
tiques sont porteurs de la bactérie Borellia.
Cette bactérie provoque, chez l’Homme,
la maladie de Lyme.
Les chercheurs ont aussi piégé plus d’un
millier de petits mammifères (des mulots,
des campagnols et des musaraignes) : ces animaux
transportent les tiques et leurs permettent,
en les nourrissant, de devenir adultes. Ils
sont les premiers contaminés par la bactérie
Borellia, lorsque les tiques les piquent.
Cette recherche, qui fait l’objet de la
thèse de Grégoire Perez, permet de comprendre
la circulation des bactéries dans le paysage
rural, pour mieux comprendre et combattre
la maladie de Lyme. Chaque année en France,
27 000 personnes tombent malades, piqués
par une tique qui a d’abord voyagé sur
le museau ou les oreilles d’un petit mammifère.